وصل الطقس الأكثر دفئًا
وسنعرض لك بعض النصائح السهلة حول
كيفية زراعة حديقتك الخاصة والحفاظ عليها
عضوية وللمساعدة في بدء الأمور ،
سنستخدم خبير البستنة في مستودع المنزل
داني واتسون لإطلاعنا على
المكان  هناك العديد من الفوائد
لامتلاك حديقتك الخاصة في الواقع ، تُظهر بعض الدراسات
أنه يمكن أن يحسن صحتك ويساعدك على
العيش لفترة أطول ويمكن أن يساعد أيضًا في الحفاظ
على البيئة عن طريق الاستغناء عن
سلاسل التوريد المهدرة التي
تنتج منتجات عضوية محلية لك ولعائلتك
أثناء  توفير المال في نفس الوقت
، وإذا كنت مبتدئًا ، فمن الأفضل أن
تبدأ صغيرًا
وتواصل طريقك
إذا كنت تعيش في مساحة محدودة أو
شقة ، يمكنك حتى زراعة الأعشاب أو
الخضار على حافة النافذة ،
ستساعدك مجموعات البذور هذه على النمو.  العملية
طالما أنها موضوعة بالقرب من مصدر
للضوء الطبيعي
إذا كان لديك مساحة بالخارج ، فإن
الطريقة الرائعة لبدء حديقتك الخاصة هي باستخدام
سرير مرتفع مثل هذا داني ، ساعدني في
تجميع هذا السرير الرائع  ربما
يمكنك إخبارنا قليلاً عن ذلك ،
بالتأكيد نستخدم الأرز في هذا الأمر ، وإليكم
ما هو لطيف حول الأرز فهو يقاوم التعفن
والحشرات إنه خالي من المواد الكيميائية
وخاصة إذا كنت تصبح
عضويًا ، فمن المهم أيضًا البحث عن
تربة جيدة حقًا هذا هو  منتج عضوي نستخدمه ،
إنه لطيف ، إنه غني ، إنه جيد التهوية وهذا
ما تريده حتى تعمل خضرواتك
بشكل جيد ، أحد الأخطاء الشائعة في البستنة للمبتدئين
هو اكتظاظ حديقتك ، لذا فأنت
تريد مساحتها وإعطاء كل شيء
مساحة كافية لزراعة
بعض النباتات الرائعة لتبدأ بها
ستكون الطماطم والفلفل
والباذنجان وبالطبع الجميع يحب الريحان عندما
تذهب لاختيار الطماطم الخاصة بك لا
تستبعد الحصول على بعض أصناف الإرث التي
أحبها فهي
غنية جدًا بالعصارة كما أنها تأتي في مجموعة من
الألوان المختلفة لذلك  تجعل
البستنة تعرف نوعًا من المرح بمجرد أن
تكون نباتاتك في الأرض أحد
أهم الأشياء التي يمكنك القيام بها لإنشاء
حديقة صديقة للبيئة هو تجنب
المواد الكيميائية الاصطناعية واستخدام
فيرتى العضوية  يمكن أن تساعد اللازمات التي
تضيف نشارة طبيعية أو حتى أوراق
فوق حديقتك التربة في
الاحتفاظ بالرطوبة وتقليل الحاجة إلى
الماء ، حيث إن المبيدات الحشرية ومبيدات
الحشائش يمكن أن تضر أكثر من السلع ،
لذا تأكد من تجنب هذه المركبات القاسية
التي قد تقتل بعض آفات الحديقة  ولكن
يمكنهم أيضًا قتل النحل والحشرات
المحلية وخلق جريان سام يتدفق
إلى مجارينا المائية ، ثم إذا كان
لديك غزو الحشرات ، فإن زيت النيم
منتج رائع لاستخدامه ، فهذا
صابون طبيعي تمامًا بالإضافة إلى صابون مبيد للحشرات ، لكنني
سأخبرك إذا  تخرج
كل يوم في حديقتك
وتراقب الحشرات التي لا تحتاج حتى إلى استخدام
أي بخاخات على الإطلاق ،
شيء واحد يجب مراعاته في حديقتك المرتفعة
هو محاولة دمج
النباتات المحلية التي تم تكييفها بالفعل
مع البيئة  يستخدمون كمية أقل من المياه
ويفكرون أيضًا في زراعة بعض
نباتات الملقحات مثل عباد الشمس التي
ستساعد في جذب النحل إلى حديقتك ،
ونأمل أن تساعد هذه النصائح في تحويل
حديقتك إلى نجمة رائعة  ر بينما
تحسن صحتك وكذلك
الكواكب
[موسيقى]
لك